so guys season 2 finale ends with Archie
getting arrested where do we pick up in
season 3 the trial yeah for them for the
arrest the murder of Cassidy Bullock yes
yeah it's a Korean episode really great
episode
your daughter Veronica is in as
displaying some independence how does
that affect your characters mm-hmm wolf
with my character it's I mean you know
he adores his daughter he goes about
showing that in the most ridiculous ways
so he's you know he's he's coming to
terms with it and then you know
everything he tries is usually wrong so
there's gonna be plenty of that with
Hermione and Veronica she's been trying
to get her not to get to this point like
I think she's known from the beginning
don't push him so hard you're not gonna
like what comes back at you and I think
this is where we're at in the beginning
of season 3 like any real parents right
the family business again I hope so
you know it's such a complex kind of you
know underworld thing you know obviously
I want to speak for you but for her my
niece character Miko I mean um
Marisol character Hermione she's the
mayor so there's that's part of the
family business as well so that'll be
interesting how she straddles that line
with my nefarious you know dealings on
the south side it's gonna say what does
Kelly think of this kind of dark role
that you're playing oh she loves it she
loves it yeah she's a role you've been
born to you were born to play your
character Frank's Archie for the murder
of Cassidy how will that affect
Veronica's relationship with Archie well
you know he doesn't really want them to
be together so it's going it's playing
right into his plan he wants us to keep
them separate and what better way to
keep them separate to throw your
daughter's boyfriend in jail like you do
or juvie you know so it's gonna be rough
for them will we see any crossovers with
Sabrina the Teenage Witch I hope so
I think so because we were fortunate
enough to see the the two first episodes
of Sabrina it's so good it's an are sort
of storyline I think kind of mirrors
just a little bit what's going on in
Greendale so I really hope so
is
something you guys are like pushing for
or if you've just heard rumblings about
it or you're like no I mean I I'm I'm a
fan of the show like Marysol said I got
to see a couple episodes of it's so good
yeah good if you could have your way
what would you dream like what storyline
would you dream up for your characters
I'm living it right ha ha
so I can't think of anything else I mean
I'm having such a good time how about
you I want to see a War of the Roses
between wouldn't it be funny I like who
moves out like that's it I mean it's
just like war exactly I run over here oh
you run over my sports car or sports car
affricate who sues so I want to see them
like yeah I think it'd be fun are we
gonna see another musical episode I am
sure euros that's the only thing you
sing sometimes yeah
it's bending it depends on the song I
can fake a shower about a car exactly
right good acoustics yeah why not yeah
what can fans expect for the season then
well more of everything more of
everything yet he lodges it's like I'm
able from hiram obviously you know as
evil as he was last year maybe a little
more evil if that's possible and for
Hermione she's gonna be forced to you
know she's been riding both sides she's
gonna be forced to have to make a
decision either way and stand her ground
so I'm excited about that